[Music]
the Bible says in Proverbs Hope deferred
makes the heart sick
when you lose hope it makes your heart
sick and here's what happens to a lot of
folks they become bitter when they lose
hope because they feel stuck and they
don't know what to do so they lash out
at anything except themselves find
something in someone to blame right it's
the government's fault it's the man's
fault it's the administration's it's the
GOP it's the Democrats it's Dave
Ramsey's fault it's dr. Phil's fault
Oprah did it I don't know who did it but
somebody did it it couldn't have been me
and when you lose hoping you get stuck
and then you try to intellectually
defend your lost hope it makes you look
foolish and so what happens is I get all
this stuff and you if you read anything
out there floating around the internet
pretty quickly you'll find a lot of Dave
Ramsey hate stuff but most of it is
based in that right there it's I told
you you could win I told you it can
happen you have lost hope and don't
believe it can happen and are bitter and
so I am evil for that reason and I have
to be marginalized otherwise the message
that I bring might have some validity
and it might make you deal with you and
so for instance I got into a thread the
other day of these angry Millennials
yeah you know if you listen this show
very much I'm a huge fan of Millennials
but I'm talking about angry entitled
snowflakes that are that are really just
pissed off at everything because they
feel stuck and they're bitter and this
whole thing of you know Dave Ramsey
doesn't understand I even won the guy
was like I hate baby boomers what really
get out much son I mean really
you hate all baby boomers that's okay
you know but that's this is what you get
when you use social media so you know
this young lady you know when these
anger snowflakes Dave Ramsey posted a
video about how student loans are stupid
when trying to build wealth and I just
want to know how he suggests
first-generation low-income students get
an education on their
to actually generate wealth building
income without obtaining student loans I
just want to know that which means that
she doesn't think it can be done by the
way I just out of curiosity I clicked on
our little profile thingy and
undergraduate and Fannie Fashion
Merchandising on her profile or Twitter
profile master's degree in education and
currently working on a PhD at a very
expensive private university very
expensive I won't name the university
because I'm not trying to get you guys
to attack this girl it's not about the
girl it's about the concept but I mean
so apparently I mean it's not just we
have to have money to get an education
we have to have more degrees than a
thermometer I mean this chick is
collecting degrees at a rapid rate and
an expensive rate too so I got to
thinking about it have you heard the
thing that tuition has gone up so much
since you were in college you baby
boomers you just don't understand
inflation adjusted tuition the cost of
college colleges are evil they have gone
through the roof have you heard this
Baird this argument it's generally done
with a high pitch like that as if it was
a beagle chasing rabbit have you heard
the argument okay if you haven't heard
it you haven't heard the whole college
discussion the cost of college and the
student loan debts are evil and that
everybody's been taking advantage of
right so I got to thinking about it it
has gone up a lot now I've been telling
people I've been on the air for almost
30 years I've been teaching this
material staying out of debt for living
on a budget paying cash for things for
almost 30 years
and all during that 30 years I've been
citing various studies that indicate
that the inflation rate of tuition is
around 7% and so for instance if you
invested your kids college fund and a
good mutual fund and it made 10 or 12%
your mutual funds going up faster than
the cost of inflation so you're in good
shape now inflation in general is
measured by the CPI the Consumer Price
Index and it has averaged around 2.9
percent for the last 40 years
okay so tuition is going up at our 7%
rate
everything else is going up at about a
3% rate now I'm 58 so I was in college I
graduated in 1982 and so I got to
thinking I wonder if they're right I
wonder if the math stands up to what
they say and so I remember what I paid
because I could barely get the money
together I paid two hundred and thirty
five dollars a quarter tuition so four
quarters in a year there's you know to
go to school for a year was 940 bucks
basically a thousand dollars a year
right to go to college in 1982 I
graduated now if you inflation-adjusted
42 $940 from 1982 at the normal
inflation rate of 2.9 percent that means
if tuition was going up like everything
else was going up that would instead of
being nine hundred forty dollars to go
to college would be just under 3000 okay
but tuition at the University of
Tennessee where I graduated from is not
three thousand dollars a year I looked
it up it's thirteen thousand six dollars
for in-state tuition for a year right
now so I wonder what 940 to thirteen
thousand six is since 1982 what's that
percentage increase what's the inflation
rate of tuition at the University of
Tennessee where I got my degree in the
in-state college put it in the
calculator 7.16% tuition inflates at
about a 7% rate and has since I got out
of school and it's continued to so let's
talk about this for saying can you get
up kid you can't can you get $13,000 a
year I mean if you're lower-income you
cannot have lower income house can you
work and make $13,000 a year yeah
yeah you can't I mean to start with in
the summer is when you're off you work
80 hours a week right and you don't work
some stupid but minimum wage job you get
it you know you walk dogs you clean
toilets you get something where you
babysit where you're making you know 15
20 bucks an hour and you can do that
walking dogs cleaning toilets and
babysitting delivering pizza you know
driving uber you you make more than
minimum wage okay
so can you come up with $13,000 in a
year that's a little over thousand
dollars a month you can make that
working part-time while you're in school
that doesn't cover housing and it
doesn't cover books it doesn't cover
food I guess still got to cover those
but that's tuition so can you do that
the answer is yes you can do that today
you could go debt-free to school now you
can't go to school where it's a little
snap snowflake that's angry at me is
going to school because that's expensive
because I did look up Vanderbilt which
is in my town and Vanderbilt is not
$13,000 here Vanderbilt is forty nine
thousand eight and ten dollars a year a
fatter bill is a wonderful school that's
four times as much by the way there's
university it's a wonderful school is it
four times better well crap no
absolutely not I know that because I
went to University of Tennessee and
people that worked or went to Vanderbilt
work for me so I don't know that that
makes you know if you've got the money
and you want to spend 50 grand a year on
Vanderbilt that's fine but don't tell me
you can't go to school debt-free you've
chosen not to go to school debt-free and
you've chosen to stay in school so long
that you're gonna be mummified by the
time you get out collecting all these
degrees this is what your problem is
kiddo this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]